[Music]
wow never gets old that spacex rocket
lit up the sky at the kennedy space
center overnight it's carrying a new
crew of astronauts to the international
space station three of them are
americans who will live and work with
three russians at a time as you know
when tensions are high between the two
countries mark straussman is at the
kennedy space center good morning to you
marky mark it looks like that space
launch went very well
good morning to you gail and you're
absolutely right it does never get old
but i've got to tell you there's
something about night launches that are
especially spectacular this one was no
exception and now after a week of delays
this crew will spend all day catching up
to the iss which is flying ten times
faster than a speeding bullet
three
two
one
for the second time in three weeks
spacex is sending people to the space
station this time professional
astronauts dragon separation confirmed
it is a privilege to get to fly this new
vehicle the crew dragon freedom to orbit
we're feeling great and looking forward
to the view tonight around eight o'clock
eastern time the crew of four will dock
to their new home away from home 250
miles above earth three americans nasa
astronauts chell lindgren the mission
commander pilot bob hines and jessica
watkins a geologist
italian astronaut samantha
christoferetti makes this an
international crew hcl is three decimal
three the thirty three-year-old watkins
has trained for a walk in space and a
walk into space history for more than 20
years astronauts have lived aboard the
iss
watkins will become the first black
female astronaut to live on the space
station for an extended time i do think
that that's you know an important
milestone for the agency and for the
country it certainly has been important
to me in my life to have role models
that looked like me are coming from
backgrounds similar to mine in a spacex
dragon spacecraft named freedom this
crew has to fly above russia's invasion
of ukraine
u.s russian interdependence keeps the
iss in orbit waiting for this morning's
crew to arrive
three cosmonauts our lives depend on
them their lives depend on us and we
have an incredibly good relationship in
2015 mission commander chell lindgren's
first trip to the iss was in a russian
soyuz he's also trained in russia
although long before the ukraine crisis
we recognize that it is an area where
emotions
are probably high and so it's probably a
topic that we'll not spend a whole lot
of time discussing on orbit is it
painful for you
at this point to see what's happening
anytime you see conflict
and you see suffering it's it's painful
again we have to focus on our mission
and what we have to accomplish on the
space station
this crew will be busy over the next
five months or so they'll perform more
than 200 science experiments they're
relieving another crew that has been up
in space since november they'll splash
down off the florida coast next week and
gail i got to believe no matter how fun
any trip is
it's always great to come home i i think
so too mark but there's always that
moment when they lift off that you go
okay okay okay so when it works it's
really beautiful to see thank you so
much always good to see you